in dieser woche hat der deutsche
bundestag den untersuchungsausschuss zum
wirecard skandal offiziell auf den weg
gebracht zeit würzen erstmals ist ein
dax konzern insolvenz so extrem peinlich
für den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
wirecard hat sich als online
zahlungsabwickler 1,9 milliarden und
sein ganzes asien geschäft komplett
ausgedacht luftbuchung jahre lang ist
das keinem aufgefallen warum nicht kann
es eventuell sein dass man das in berlin
einfach zu geil fand dass wir mit
wirecard wenigstens noch einen global
player im finanz business hatten
papperlapapp wenn ich das mal sagen darf
nein darfst du nicht du kanzlerkandidat
olaf scholz musste sich dazu diese woche
im bundestag einiges anhören
und zwar zu recht auch wegen seiner
erschreckenden gedächtnislücken im
hamburger comex skandal wenn man die
glauben will und jan marsalek einer der
wirecard haupttäter ist derweil weiter
auf der flucht
schild wahrscheinlich irgendwo mit juan
carlos von spanien
jan marsalek jetzt schon men of the year
auf der titelseite der neuen illegaler
wirecard wirecard hat unter anderem
kleinanleger um 3,2 milliarden euro
betrogen warum zum teufel hat die
kanzlerin persönlich noch letzten
september in china für diesen laden
werbung gemacht wenn du wer hat sie denn
da bitte eingelagert es war tatsächlich
so dass karl theodor zu guttenberg und
das ist eben die neue qualität der ist
nicht vorstellig geworden bei der
bundeskanzlerin als berater sondern als
ex-minister und als freund ja also
sozusagen in der hülle sozusagen des
freundes die hülle des freundes seine
beste rolle
nach der hölle des doktortitel trägers
kurz davor karl-theodor ernsthaft noch
für diese komische autor firmiert er
macht echt mit jedem der vogel
freundinnen ihn schon karl theodor zu
guttenberg wieso kriegt der facetime mit
der kanzlerin wie so kann sich merkel
auch gleich mit dem abou chaker treffen
wenn sage ich wenn dann müssten alle
bürger mit merkel sprechen dürfen egal
für welches pillepalle anliegen
ich will hier mit ein video an mein
enkel marvin verschicken
wie mache ich das illegale hundekämpfe
veranstalten der bundestag
ich habe da hinten so ein ausschlag
können sie mich mal dann kratzen
ich fänds verwirklich soll sich alles
mal anhören die feine dame da nur zwei
tage nach dem gespräch mit freund
guttenberg ist wirecard auf ihrer to do
liste für die china-reise gelandet
schämte sich im nachhinein wenn ich es
ein bisschen dass es passieren kann dass
man zu einem zeitpunkt wo man von
solchen unregelmäßigkeiten keine
kenntnis hat man sich für ein
unternehmen auch einsetzt
das halte ich auch für gegeben hält so
viel gegeben ja sicher sicher im herbst
2009 10 konnte das alles keiner wissen
kein mensch also außer die leute die
2015 diesen fetten artikel in der
financial times gelesen haben oder
diesen aus dem spiegel von 2016 oder
diesen aus dem manager magazin von 2017
ja weil dafür hätte die kanzlerin ja
regelrecht googeln müssen diesen neuland
man hat ihr halt erzählt wirecard wer
grundsolider seriöser deutscher
mittelstand der aufstieg von wirecard
war rasant vom zahlungsabwickler für
porno und glücksspielseiten zum global
player
jetzt verstehe ich dass wirecard war
eigentlich so eine art kassierer im
pornokino nur halt im internet in diesem
skandal haben wirklich alle
kontrollinstanzen komplett versagt
wirecard hatte doch zum beispiel einen
aufsichtsrat gut vw hatte auch ein
aufsichtsrat
er war trotzdem vielleicht sollten wir
in liebe kinder dass man grundsätzlich
erklären was macht eigentlich so ein
aufsichtsrat da sitzen abgehalfterte ex
manager des konzerns aber natürlich auch
abgehalfterte ex politiker plus meistens
noch eine alibi gewerkschafts tussi und
die essen dann offenbar hauptsächlich
kekse und wenn die kekse alle sind dann
gehen sie nach hause und kriegen dafür
sehr sehr viel geld
das ist es im wesentlichen mehr ist es
nicht genauso versagt haben die ask
euren wirtschaftsprüfer von ernst &
young aber auch die bafin zum begriff
oder bafin ist eine abkürzung für
bundesanstalt für irgendwie nichts
nachdem die financial times ausdrücklich
vor gefälschten bilanzen bei wirecard
gewarnt hat ist die bafin hier dem nicht
etwa nachgegangen nein die haben die
journalisten an gezeigt warum
unterdessen wurde bekannt dass
mitarbeiter der bundesanstalt für
finanzaufsicht bis juni mit keine aktie
so viel gehandelt haben die mit der von
wirecard bafin mitarbeiter handel mit
aktien von firmen die sie kontrollieren
soll jetzt verboten werden cool sehr
gutes timing tatsächlich kontrolliert
wurde wirecard am ende von einem typen
bei der sogenannten deutschen prüfstelle
für rechnungslegung der aber und ich
wünschte wirklich das wäre ein witz
fragebögen zur selbstauskunft an
wirecard verschickt sonst nichts
dabei hätte man diese gangster so leicht
überführen könnten so leicht und zwar so
hier ich zeigt sie ja nur einmal deren
bank auf den philippinen anrufen wenn
halo bafin hier sagen sie mal hat die
firma wirecard bei euch ein konto mit
knapp 2 milliarden drauf war er karls
also ehrlich gesagt noch nie gehört
danke ende der ermittlungen
er wäre es nicht gewesen deutschland
offenbar ein paradies für kriminelle
firmen deutsche bank mannesmann siemens
vw endlose liste gut vom fall wirecard
kann man ja schockiert sein oder sich
davon inspirieren lassen wie mein
kollege ulrich von heesen der heute am
berliner kanzleramt für seine eigene
firma lobbyiert ulrich was ist das denn
für eine firma schwer zu erklären dass
das ist ein start up basierend auf einer
app also im prinzip geht es um content
management für junge weibliche
gründerinnen die über pay per view ihr
volles marktpotential ausschöpfen können
also eine pornoseite ja klar
übrigens noch investoren welche wenn sie
da privat mal was rein stecken wollen ja
danke warum sollte doktor angela merkel
bitte eine pornoseite unterstützen
doch auch gemacht und meine firma ist
viel seriöser frisch gegründet die
trickfilm an e.on ag ich bin
geschäftsführer zusammen mit einem
nigerianischen prinzen den ich im
internet kennengelernt habe ganz feiner
kerl
sind sie jetzt kriminell oder was er
natürlich in diesem land nicht kriminell
sein ist schlicht blöd wir haben nicht
mal richtiges strafrecht für unternehmen
firmen kriegen bußgelder von maximal
zehn millionen euro
da wirst du noch quasi zum bescheißen
gezwungen
wenn es so einfach ist der massa lag
unsere mutmaßlichen milliardenbetrug zu
decken sollte 40 jährige schauspieler
engagiert haben
die bankmitarbeiter spielen er soll
sogar kulissen errichtet haben um
vorzutäuschen dass es sich um bank
zweigstellen handelt papa brände ein mit
buntstift aufgemalter tresor fertigte
bank ist genial war jetzt auch also ich
habe noch kein geld für schauspieler
aber ich hab da einen jungen mann im
büro der mein buchhalter spielt falls
doch mal eine betriebsprüfung kommen das
ist mein enkel justin hier bringt er
unsere erste milliarde nach zürich der
wird nie kontrolliert weil der so süß
welche unser staat guckt doch zum teil
auch absichtlich weg bei turniers zum
beispiel wussten alle dass der seit
jahren massiv gegen den arbeitsschutz
verstößt bis dahin gut vernetzt sein
dann tut dir keiner was so genug
geplaudert ich muss da jetzt rein eine
runde lobbyieren die merkel soll für
mich werbung in china machen zum quatsch
sie können da noch niemals rein
ach nein doch ich bin kumpel von
guttenberg muss mit der kanzlerin
sprechen es geht um eine pornoseite wenn
was schiefgeht wir sehen uns auf den
philippinen alter schlawiner ulrich von
heesen
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye